[Music]
in maximizing space news submitted by
Elena Elaine a landlord is facing
massive fines for splitting up a condo
nine ways to create illegal illegal
micro-units
HIV that we had a neighbor that did that
like there was like people in the
kitchen that micro-units matt girl units
like having 20 roommates in macro it
smells [ __ ] Chinese like a
[ __ ] these week airplane I
haven't seen these but my mom's
contractor took so there's these type of
places all over my park yeah and so my
mom she had bought a house in Monterey
Park is she converted just a regular
home into like a triplex and then so she
was kind of proud and then my mom's
contractor was like oh yeah you want to
see some crazy [ __ ] and then he took her
to this place where maybe in like a
7,000 square feet of land so you know
like where you live right now that whole
lot of that is probably around 7,000
square feet he is able to charge 30
people rent and one of them was like a
garage of the house he just put up
boards and there was 11 beds in just the
garage yeah cuz people they come here
and they need a place to stay so they're
like oh if I can only pay 100 or 150 a
month for a place to stay we all share
the hotel yeah it's a hostel yeah that
lot was like 30 residences so it's like
you're hella good money I like though
he's competing with your mom she's like
I did a good job he's like really [ __ ]
you're not maximizing your shelf space
girl snored wait what the [ __ ] I think
you're taking advantage of people that
are just trying to make the living here
I think it's taking advantage because
then it's not safe conditions it's
applying demand oh so the people that
are coming here they're looking for $50
a month rent your daughter
month rent don't be it's wrong and
before yet I think it's wrong for sure
it's inhumane from our standards or from
their point of view they are looking
forward to this so yeah you don't come
to the states and then go ah [ __ ] this
is the only place I can stay they're
already back in China where the [ __ ]
they're from they're like Oh what Jimmy
yang says that I can find the place for
rent for 50 bucks
sign me up let me work three years buy
an airplane ticket I'm gonna be Jimmy
Yang's neighbor in that garage from
there cuz imagine if you're like oh my
god I kind of spent $2,000 and I only
make 2500 in America like that's
everything right yeah but then if you in
like like all of us were like hey let's
all just pitch in and get an apartment
together we're just gonna just sleep
there anyway that's the college life and
then we're like well it's I get out and
[ __ ] and they're like we'll [ __ ] you I
want to live here with my with these
people yeah I don't even give a [ __ ]
about the code because I want to live
here for cheap and I know that in 10
years I'm gonna buy a real house or some
point and then you get the bubonic
plague because it takes place in New
York and it's a 634 square-foot
manhattan condo that won't happen
horizontally so it's [ __ ] do you guys
remember being John Malkovich where they
had the 7th and a half Manhattan office
yeah I never watched it it's like when
they're all like crouching down
oh it's like a hobbits apartment oh oh
my but they put like right here yeah I
have to say having lived with my hoarder
mother this looks pretty good
my mom's like like not dead animals in
there but everything like the TV quality
hoarders show she can make the good yo
this isn't even as bad as Hong Kong
slums yeah the cages Hong Kong slums are
[ __ ] sad it looks like a it's like a
vet for humans it
like like there's just stacks of just
bunk beds
yeah cages yeah it's [ __ ] weird so he
doors
so this landlord he created nine units
from that one 600 and something square
foot nine units I said 34 contractors
going that's genius
[ __ ] you're telling me I could have got
60 people by splitting the house in half
[ __ ] I'll see Being John Malkovich yeah
maybe they watched the movie and had the
idea
and don't mention years Chinese by the
way
I know it smell tiny you needed to
mention that we hadn't painted the
picture just to confirm yeah and so
people discovered this because there
were like five oh [ __ ] well me she's
giving them a CD yeah he actually cares
about it I know crazy
I mean there's no sunlight and a lot of
these units as well but AC goes a long
way for sure and so once they discovered
this day had everyone leave pretty much
back then look at it and decided I'm
gonna report that because it's inhumane
yeah like this just not so right from
your perspective what do you feel like
what do you feel is that how is it like
mean or inhumane or you feel like
they're being taken aback I think
they're being taken advantage of and
it's not a a humane way to minute so you
feel like they don't have other choices
to stay anywhere else yeah so once they
discovered this um the authorities like
they sent them to the American Red Cross
to have emergency what is it emergency
care housing Oh
can I ask what city this is a Manhattan
oh no [ __ ] wonder they're getting a
deal
[Laughter]
it's $1,000 per cubby right 100 a month
yeah I'm let's tiptoe where that's
expensive dude Manhattan it's like
[ __ ] 5 G's a month and [ __ ] yeah
Lower East Side and they're all are they
all like undocumented immigrants and all
that yeah so the landlord was fined more
than a hundred and forty four thousand
dollars for failing to have sprinklers
pot proper proper and electrical
structural strongly advocate in plumbing
government if there was a fire there
they're all they're [ __ ] yeah when
they're saying when you're saying you're
with TIF on this and you think they're
taking advantage of yeah I think it's a
type of exploitation like yes on one
hand they obviously needed it like no
one's doing this by choice
or I mean well yeah probably not by
choice because they just they don't have
the means to go anywhere else so then if
they're if the landlord's willing to cut
it in half yeah he puts an AC or
whatever but like what other things is
he cutting corners on like that this the
sprinkler situation like are there rats
like but that's why it's only 600 bucks
that's why it's our deal G but then
that's like we have right that's that we
have laws no because we've probably did
this in the past and we heard from that
so we're like oh let's not do that
anymore and have everyone followed
there's also a market for it so like
like let's like let's say it's only
three options is stay in his fucked-up
country wherever that is come to the
states have a deal or be homeless I
don't know like to me I'm like that's
Packers work you're taking the angle of
the more it's exploitations that there's
only high prices in New York City and if
you're not a citizen or if you just come
on a work visa you don't have many
options
yeah options cuz it's so expensive too
damn high yes
so what else are they supposed to do and
then I guess you know the landlord he's
kind of shitty and he's cutting quarters
he's finding something but then people
are renting it because there aren't
options for lower rent in New York right
and Fran or May along so how do you
figure it out because dishwashers you
know contractors or laborers are like
you know low-income workers have to work
in New York too and that's probably like
kind of the thing it's the balance right
but I do get the whole other side of
like landlords have to be responsible
and think about the overall picture of
these guys is like cuz I doubt this
guy's doing it out of the kindness of
his power no he's doing it for [ __ ]
get off it yeah yeah you rented it to 11
tenants by the way and there was also
another there was an illegal bathroom in
the unit and then he I mean at least he
does have a kind enough heart illegal
additional bathroom yes
so what's worse no one legal bathrooms
or five illegal what constitutes the
bathroom is it a bucket and a sink
flushable bucket
RV toilet this landlord site is like
luxurious the deluxe bathroom and it's
like a [ __ ] bucket I ve seen those
[ __ ] bug-out toilets where it's just
the [ __ ] bucket with a toilet seat
yes so he plays full wrap to prevent
tenants from hitting their heads on
pipes night floor does care a little bit
weird as [ __ ] the slump in diameter he's
a guy I would die he's like I can't have
these people hitting heads because then
they can't go working in the camp making
more money
he's a slumlord yeah slumlord
millionaire there was also another unit
that had a similar set up above him Wow
oh my god some another Chinese guy I'm
surprised there's not sleeping bags
hanging out of windows nature you're
with nature see you just have to find a
good real estate agent to word it right
I know this sounds crazy but I'm not
following laws and like you know people
can get all kinds of disease and stuff
but so my dad was probably one of the
first wave of immigrants for my
communist China to come to the states
and then back then they had to go to
China Hong Kong route and then Hong Kong
to the States and so they had to do like
two layers of refugees and when he and
back then since they
have like the Underground Railroad of
China and like a harriet tubman chen to
[ __ ] like establish everything they
had to do things themselves right so my
dad he got to hong kong and he found a
restaurant that was willing to let him
work there and he volunteered to be the
janitor so he can clean and wash
everything and he'll just sleep under
one of the table free while working for
a little bit of pay and he got enough
money to to hear about someone else that
be willing to take him in to do
something else so he would have this
would have been like winning the lottery
gym if there was Harriet Tubman Chan
that was able to tell him about all do
come here only six hundred bucks a month
you could work in the epicenter of New
York where there's tons of work for you
to find he would have been like bug yeah
I would prefer your dad sleep underneath
the [ __ ] the the table or whatever
because at least it's probably more
sanitary than nobody here what I love
this though but that's also illegal
because you can't sleep in your
restaurant but no one's doing any like
he's the only one doing shady [ __ ]
because he he just got creative but this
guy like I said he's just taking
advantage of well there's like 11 other
people that are sleeping under the table
now about get to sleep with AC yeah cuz
I think the it's it's the perspective of
like a lot of these refugees are
grateful for it but then for us we're
like that's no way to live
depends on where you came from yeah yeah
yeah depends where you came from a mud
hut I'm this is great for me I don't
care about bubonic I'm good yeah alright
cuz you're like damn it's either that or
this I'd rather take this but then
people are saying we should even give
them that option we should give them a
more decent option so they can live
haven't been an option yeah yeah free
the landlord that's what you're saying
an innocent man going down once again
he's just trying to help the world
[Music]
[Music]